[Musica]
vi è mai capitato
guardando il cielo stellato di
meravigliarvi di fronte all'immensità
dell'universo e chiedervi se siamo soli
se la terra è l'unico luogo in cui la
vita sia mai esistita
sulla terra la vita è ovunque la vita e
tenace al punto tale che i microrganismi
definiti estremofili sono stati in grado
di adattarsi alle condizioni più estreme
di temperatura
acidità salinità radioattività
colonizzando in questo modo anche i
posti più ostili del nostro pianeta e
dimostrando che una volta che i processi
viventi si sono innescati la vita trova
il modo di conservarsi mutando se stessa
per sopravvivere
allora per cercare vita oltre la terra
bisogna puntare a quei luoghi che hanno
almeno hanno avuto nel passato delle
condizioni simili a quelle che sulla
terra hanno portato all'origine della
vita
marte un buon candidato in tal senso in
quanto nel periodo in cui sulla terra
emergevano le prime forme viventi circa
4 miliardi di anni fa
marte presentava condizioni simili alla
terra e molteplici ambienti abitabili in
grado cioè di supportare la vita
tali condizioni però non si sono
mantenute a lungo essendo infatti marte
molto piccolo
il suo nucleo si è raffreddato
rapidamente determinando lo spegnimento
del suo campo magnetico senza campo
magnetico il vento solare ha
gradualmente eroso l'atmosfera la
temperatura si è abbassata
l'acqua non è stata mantenuta allo stato
liquido sulla superficie
radiazioni dannose particelle
energetiche hanno potuto penetrare
attraverso la sottile atmosfera marziana
e indurre la formazione di specie
ossidanti nel suolo in poche centinaia
milioni di anni marte si è trasformato
in un deserto arido e gelido
determinando potenzialmente l'estinzione
di eventuali forme di vita marziana
anche in questo caso tuttavia tracce
della loro passata esistenza potrebbero
essere rinvenute nelle rocce più antiche
che su marte sono tuttora ben preservate
data l'assenza di una tettonica a
placche che invece sulla terra ha
provocato grandi trasformazioni della
superficie cancellando le tracce delle
forme di vita più primitive sviluppate
se sul nostro pianeta marte offre ancora
oggi una fotografia di un passato che
sulla terra è stato spazzato via e
quindi potrebbe darci informazioni
su quella che è stata all'origine della
vita sulla terra stessa
questo è un esempio di alcuni dei
fossili più antichi che possono essere
rinvenuti sulla terra una stromatoliti
di 2,7 miliardi di anni che ho raccolto
a fibra in australia occidentale e in
cui è ancora possibile vedere delle
strutture a strati che rappresentano le
tracce indirette lasciate nella roccia
da antichissimi microrganismi
unicellulari i cianobatteri
talvolta in queste rocce e possibile
ancora rinvenire della materia organica
che ha resistito ai processi di
degradazione verificatesi nel tempo per
cercare tracce come queste su marte che
noi astrobiology chiamiamo baio
signature la nasa ha inviato il rover
perseverance ad ispezionare il cratere
jazz rowe il sito di un antico lago un
nuovo potenzialmente abitabile nel
passato di martin il mio lavoro come
membro del team scientifico di questa
missione consiste nell'analizzare i dati
acquisiti in situ quegli strumenti che
sono a bordo del rover e aiutare a
selezionare i campioni più interessanti
da prelevare all'interno di speciali
tubi che perseverance lascerà sulla
superficie di marte in attesa di essere
riportati successivamente sulla terra
attraverso una serie di missioni
congiunte dell'agenzia spaziale
americana europea
portare frammenti di marte sulla terra
sarà un'impresa straordinaria mai
tentata prima che farà riscrivere i
libri di storia nel 2026 sarà lanciato
un altro rover dotato di un braccio
meccanico in grado di raccogliere i tubi
contenenti campioni marziani lasciati da
per sé vira sulla superficie di marte
che saranno poi trasferiti all'interno
di un razzo e lanciati in orbita
marziana per poi essere poi catturati da
una sonda orbitante e riportati sulla
terra nel 2031
ancora dieci anni e permetteremo a
generazioni e generazioni di futuri
scienziati di svelare segreti del
pianeta marte attraverso un'analisi
dettagliata dei campioni marziani
utilizzando le strumentazioni più
d'avanguardia che saranno disponibili
nel futuro nei nostri laboratori
terrestri
un'altra missione fondamentale per la
ricerca della vita su marte sarà poi
exomars 2022 dell'agenzia spaziale
europea e russa che esplorerà per la
prima volta nella storia il sottosuolo
raggiungendo fino a due metri di
profondità attraverso l'utilizzo di un
trapano a tali profondità ci aspettiamo
una minore degradazione da parte di
radiazioni ossidanti e in generale un
ambiente più favorevole a preservare
possibili vaio signature
oppure addirittura la presenza di
nicchia ancora abitabili in cui
eventuali microorganismi marziani
potrebbero essere sopravvissuti
insomma queste missioni potrebbero
davvero aiutarci a capire se c'è mai
stata vita oltre la terra
rispondendo ad uno dei quesiti più
importanti dei programmi internati
giornale di esplorazione planetaria ma
non solo
trovare tracce di vita nelle rose
antiche di marte avvalorerebbe l'ipotesi
che la vita è un imperativo
universale in grado cioè di emergere in
qualsiasi luogo dell'universo con
condizioni al contorno favorevoli come
quelli verificatisi sulla terra e su
marte circa 4 miliardi di anni fa in
presenza dei giusti ingredienti chimico
fisici
e se invece non trovassimo alcuna
traccia di vita negli ambienti che
stiamo esplorando che nel passato
possedevano condizioni favorevoli al suo
sviluppo
sicuramente una tale scoperta ci
indurrebbe a rivalutare quanto la terra
sia speciale il nostro pail blu dott
tenue puntino azzurro così come
fotografato dalla sonda voyager nel
1990 a 6 miliardi di chilometri di
distanza
un piccolo punto perso nell'immensità
dell'universo
le cui caratteristiche però sono
risultati ottimali per lo sviluppo della
vita e sono rimaste stabili così a lungo
da permettere la sua evoluzione fino al
raggiungimento di vita intelligente
l'uomo che da secoli si interroga sulla
sua stessa esistenza e per trovare
risposte alle sue domande più profonde
ha sviluppato metodi scientifici e
tecnologie sempre più sofisticate
decifrando tassello dopo tassello il
codice della natura per cercare di
risolvere la sua equazione più complessa
la vita stessa
[Applauso]
[Musica]